Like I wonder if the person that created, you know, or invented C-Serve was like, whoa, I can make, what if I force the user, let me log into my bank and see if this works, you know, like, and that's like the original write-up, you know, it's like passing around material on the dark web, like, for bank.com, you can, you know, trigger transfers.
I don't know why that's my voice for early day hackers, like maybe it's me, early 2010.
Yeah, exactly.
No, Joel, you're sitting, man.
This is, this is, if we're going to, if we're going to debate this, you need to stand up.
Okay.
Like, I just wanted to show off my new headrest, that's all.
Oh, oh, that is good looking, man.
You get a new chair?
No, no, same chair, so, oh my God, sorry, I have something in my mouth.
Yeah, sorry, I started it, like, right as you put something into your mouth.
Yeah.
What is it, like, caramel or something like that?
You're chewing like a maniac.
Yeah, it's a chewy, it's a ginger thing.
Anyways, anyways, this company, Atlas, they make, like, the Herman Miller, like, third-party headrest, and the Embody headrest has been in, like, pre-orders for, like, six months, so.
I ordered mine back in December, and it finally came, like, a week or two ago.
Dude.
So, it's been, like, a huge, huge, nice improvement to an already amazing chair.
So, yes, but that's it.
I'll stand up.
All right, that's, like, the geekiest thing I've ever, you pre-ordered a headset or a headrest for your chair.
There we go.
Now, let's rise, and let's debate, okay?
All right.
So, you say, so, before we ran the live recording, Joel was saying there's no such thing as a C-Surf on mobile.
I suspect this is a terminology difference, but, yeah.
All right.
So, here's what it is, all right?
C-Surf on mobile, let's say, for example, we talked about this, sort of, on the mobile episode.
It's, like, a deep link or, like, a, what are they called?
The app links that you can trigger that will trigger some sort of functionality in the app.
So, for example, if I have, like, if I can craft a link that, like, has, I've seen this before, has, like, a base64 encoded, you know, data blob in it,
and that file gets, like, downloaded and put onto the user's device or something like that, you know, that's not the most perfect example.
Maybe it's something along the lines of, like, add friend, you know, equals one, two, three, four.
And then, like, when you click that link, you automatically send them a friend request, right?
I feel like that's a mobile C-Surf.
Is that not?
I mean, so, like, yes and no.
I think, to some extent, you could count that as a C-Surf, but it's not really.
Like, in the classical sense, if you think about what a C-Surf is, like, a C-Surf is a cross-site request forgery, right?
Okay, okay, Joel.
Like, it's not a site.
Come on, but it's an app.
Well, yeah, but it's not a site, but it's also, like, there is no restriction that you can put in place to, like, stop this.
Like, if you click a deep link, for example, like you said, if I click a deep link for my browser, nothing that gets passed through tells the app that I clicked that from attacker.com.
Okay, okay, but, like, you could just not write functionality where someone can have a deep link that does something in the app unvalidated.
Like, there should be a screen that pops up and says, are you sure you want to add, you know, Jimmy Jim as a friend?
Yeah, sure, but, like, how do you detect that?
Well, no, there's no detection that's needed.
So, like, the reality is that, like, if you don't want this to be a thing, it has to be not exposed at all.
Like, that functionality cannot exist, right?
If you want for somebody to be able to add a friend, either you have to have a separate route that is exposed that's, like, add a friend, confirm, and then, like, when they click that, then the app does different functionality where they confirm it explicitly, but the fact that that deep link exists means that it will always be reachable if it's exposed.
So, either it can't be exposed or you have to, you know, or it either is or it isn't, right?
So, what you're saying is, like, even though that functionality, you're saying there's no way to make that functionality secure if you want to have that functionality.
Is that what you're saying?
Yeah, and so, I think, like, the caveat to this and the bug that I picked as, like, an example for this, I think the best caveat I can think of is, like, JavaScript bridges.
So, that's, like, kind of the closest you can get to, like, a C-Surf type of behavior where, say, like, within a browser, within a web view within the app, you are able to either call out to a different internal-only URL schema.
Yeah, or a JavaScript object.
Or a JavaScript bridge or something like that to trigger functionality within the app from an attacker website.
That is something that you can stop.
You can detect origin and stuff from a JavaScript bridge.
You can do all that kind of stuff.
But if, you know, it's just the fact that the deep link exists and is callable externally, I wouldn't really call that a C-Surf so much as an abuse of intended functionality.
Okay.
So, maybe that's my...
Because it's not, like, blockable.
Maybe that's my, like, web brain trying to apply it to mobile.
That's, like, the way that I've categorized it in my head to try to get, you know, it to fit into my little context, you know?
Yeah.
So, I could see that.
But I am a little disappointed, though, because I definitely wanted there to be CARF cross-app request forgery.
Like, I feel like CARF, we could just, like, can you, like, make that a vulnerability?
So, like, that kind of exists, too.
Okay.
Is that a real thing?
Yeah.
So, I think, like, that's also a thing.
For example, like, intents, right?
If, like, you create an intent from a third party app.
Right.
And you call an intent, like, that's going cross-app.
But, you know, and you can stop that stuff just like you can with the C-Serve.
Do you remember that bug from at, in LA?
Yeah.
That, that was, I feel like that's kind of like a CARF, am I right?
Yeah, yeah.
I would say that that's pretty, that's, like, a pretty good example of, like, a cross-app request forgery, a CARF.
Yeah.
If you want to call it a CARF.
Dude, all right.
Where it's basically, yeah.
Just came up with a new vulnerability name right here.
Yeah.
I mean, it's basically, and that, I think, is a really common exploitation scenario within mobile apps.
And it totally breaks CVSS because it's, like, local only.
Because, like, you'd need another app on the system for it to be exploitable.
Yeah.
But, but, yeah, no, that's, like, a really common thing where you have some functionality that's, you know, accessible from other apps on the system that is then exploitable to do all sorts of different functionality that, I mean, we've seen full RCE from that.
So, yeah, you can go anywhere from the super basic stuff to full RCE.
Where's our, um, where's our notes on the mobile episode?
Because isn't there, like, so, like, for example, if you're doing, like, a CARF, right, and you need to craft, like, an intent, there are the intent URLs, though, right?
That you can, like, almost embed it into a URL and it, like, still sends the intent?
Yeah.
If I recall correctly, that is no longer supported in, like, Chrome and Chromium.
I believe it was, like, a, it's an older Android thing, and it's up to, like, implementation, essentially, about whether or not it's supported, um, but I might be wrong.
Yeah, I'm looking back through the notes.
Well, we'll have to find that and suss it later.
Yeah.
But, all right, cool.
Well, that's our nice little debate to start us off today, whether or not mobile C-SERFs exist or whether CARF is a thing, cross app.
Yeah, CARF is definitely a thing.
CARF is a thing, man.
All right, you know what, that's going to be, I'm going to, I'm going to have to go send out a tweet right after, after this episode, CARF is a thing.
That's all I'm going to say.
CARF is a thing, no context.
Yeah, no context, just CARF is a thing.
Cool.
All right, man, let's, let's, let's get back to the news, yeah?
All right.
Yeah, for sure.
Let's see.
News is looking, I'm not going to lie, man, news was a little bit thin this week.
Yeah, I think it's just stuff's leading up to DEF CON.
People are holding their cards close to their chest.
They don't want to let everything fall just yet, but I would recommend within like two weeks, we're going to have some really crazy amounts of news that we're going to have to go through.
Yeah, dude, are you going to, are you going to try to do like any Joel solo episodes at DEF CON, you think, or at the H1702 event?
I might, I'm not going to be at DEF CON.
I'm only going to be at the H1 event.
Oh, okay.
So we'll see whether or not anybody wants to do like some recording sessions.
I'm trying to grab like an extra handheld mic that I can use as sort of like an interview type thing that I wouldn't feel bad about traveling with.
Like this mic, I probably wouldn't travel with because it's expensive and if something happened during travel, I would be very sad.
Yeah, no, I believe that, man.
I think, I just think the in-person interviews have such a good vibe, you know, with Cosmin and, and with, you know, mystery guest.
We did record two episodes when we were in London.
Yeah, that's true.
One of them hasn't been cleared for release yet.
So we've got an awesome episode in the backlog that you guys are really going to enjoy.
But yeah, I feel like those were sick.
So if we can do more of those, that would be really good, I think.
Yeah, yeah, I do plan on bringing the recorder.
So we'll, we'll, we'll definitely see.
Hopefully I'll get at least one in there.
All right, so the first news item on the list today was actually something that, that Rezo tweeted out like a couple minutes before we started recording.
And I was like, oh, we should just throw this in there.
He says, here's a bug bounty tip that I just learned from TCM security's YouTube live stream.
SQL map can use the same syntax as curl.
So if you do copy as curl in any tool, paste it into a terminal, exchange curl to SQL map, it just works.
That's crazy.
That is sick.
SQL map also lets you do like raw request inputs, right?
It does.
So you can literally just, that's one of my favorite features is you can basically just copy paste a full raw HDB request into a text file.
And then you just pipe that into SQL map.
Yeah, I think so.
And then it just parses it and it will do all the magic.
You don't have to set a different flag for cookies or any of that kind of stuff.
So yeah, it's awesome.
I want to see, I want to say Fuff also does raw request, doesn't it?
I believe it does.
Yeah.
Ref raw.
Yeah, it does dash request file containing the raw HTTP request.
I love that, man.
That's so helpful.
Yeah.
I mean, it just makes it so much easier for testing when you, when you don't have to look up all the different flags.
And if you like run it once and something's not working, or maybe it looks like it's working, but it's not actually working.
Just knowing that for sure it's using the exact request that you were using makes it so much easier to do your testing.
Yeah.
And easy to insert insertion points, both in SQL map and Fuff.
But, you know, it is very convenient when you've got a curl request as well.
Or when you're, for example, if you're finding an SQL, if you're one of those freaks that finds SQLs via just the freaking inspector tool, then, you know, you can right click and copy to curl.
And then just, I will say the first, the first SQL injection I ever found was using, uh, uh, what is it?
Hack, hack bar, hack.
Oh, no way, dude.
Yeah.
The old, old, yeah.
Oh my gosh.
This is like way back in the day.
I cannot believe that, man.
Yeah, hack bar, like the Firefox, uh, extension.
Dude, I just got like freaking teleported back to like early college, man.
Hack bar?
Yeah.
Are you serious?
Hack bar.
Yeah.
I think that's what it was called, right?
Yeah, yeah, I just, I just looked it up.
It's still a thing.
It seems like they've actually added some pretty cool features to it.
That's really cool.
That's pretty sick, man.
A lot of reviews too.
50,000 plus users.
This is a good, this is a good extension.
This is so crazy.
This is not related to security stuff, but I heard, I heard someone on, on a podcast the other day talk about marketing a product by buying Chrome extensions for like, like one cent per user, right?
Really?
Yeah.
So they're buying like, you know, 40,000 plus install apps for like 400 bucks, you know?
And it's like, wow.
I don't know how you would even market to it.
I guess maybe you'd like do some sort of invasive little pop-up ad thing, you know, push code to it.
But that, I don't know, man.
Yeah, that's really interesting.
I wonder like if that violates any of the Chrome web store rules.
Because I know that like when you uninstall an extension, there's like a report this extension type thing.
And I don't actually know if I've ever reported an extension, but I assume they ask for more info about like why you're reporting it.
So what you got to do is get the Chrome extension, use the Chrome extension to install a service worker on that page and just automatically say no to that.
Well, yeah, just take over their computer.
Actually, that's like a, that's an interesting, I don't think, I feel like Chrome extensions shouldn't be able to install service workers on specific sites, right?
I don't know.
I got to look into it.
It might be a specific permission because even when you install one, you have to grant it specific like site by site, like whatever it's requesting access to.
Yeah, okay, yeah, that makes sense.
I got to look into that though.
That would be, that'd be a fun attack vector.
Yeah.
There was this, there was this tweet you made today actually, where you were like, I'm so annoyed, like when you find an IDOR and your sessions get swapped.
So I wrote this JS bookmarklet that puts a cookie on the TLD of the target and then I use request highlighter to highlight each browser a different color.
And I do that as well, by the way.
Yeah.
That's like, thank you.
That makes me feel a little bit better.
That's the easiest way that I have for like two person testing is I have an incognito window and I have a normal window in the same browser.
And I just, you know, do a, the request highlighter extension to highlight different colors for those two sessions.
If it's like really, really complicated and I have them both open at the same time, but if it's something super straightforward, I'll usually just like copy paste my off header or whatever it is.
Yeah.
I, that's what, so that's what I do.
And then like a couple people from the freaking like Twitter went on here and were like, yo, there's already extensions to do this.
And apparently one of them is, so there's burp browser profiles.
There's auto Chrome, I think is the other one.
There's, what was the one that they said something hack Fox?
Pwn Fox.
Yeah.
That's what it is.
And actually I clicked on the Pwn Fox or Pwn Fox one.
I can't, can't say it.
I clicked on the Pwn Fox one and it looks pretty sick.
Like if you look at the highlighting within that looks really good.
So definitely could be worth using, but you know, if you're using Firefox, yuck.
Yeah, yeah, for sure.
Because that's like 0.03% of the population that uses freaking Firefox.
Yeah, way lower than I would have expected.
Same.
But actually Pwn Fox also lists, uh, listen to read me that if you're using Chrome, you can use this NCC group tool called auto Chrome.
Auto Chrome.
Yeah.
Which does a lot of like default setups and stuff.
I used to do something very similar to this where I had a shortcut, like an alias in my terminal that I would use to spin up a new Chrome instance that would run like without the XSS auditor and would have the proxy args and all that kind of stuff.
Nowadays, it's so easy to proxy Chrome and I really don't want the XSS auditor turned off if I'm being honest because it doesn't do anything anymore.
And it's such, it's such like a bar in terms of like if something is getting caught by the XSS auditor, which like you're saying, I don't actually know if it does anything anymore.
Yeah, then I probably don't want to submit that because there, what's the attack scenario where somebody has XSS auditor disabled and I'm able to exploit their Chrome?
I feel like XSS auditor got removed and the only case that I can think of that it actually, I'm not sure if this is XSS auditor or if it's something else, but is like when you, you click a link that has target equals, um, blank, uh, on it.
Right. So it's supposed to open up a new tab and that your injection is in that H ref, right?
Then I think it says no, can't do that.
Um, I was just looking, it's been fully removed as of Chrome 78.
Dude, that's so clutch, man.
Like I, I, I do remember for a brief period when that was around and it's just like, please, like, just please stop.
Like I, you know that I can bypass you.
Like, please just don't make me do it.
You know?
Yeah, for sure.
Hold on one second.
My dog's barking.
You're good.
We can pause here.
Yeah.
So dude, did you see this JS weasel thing that got released earlier this week?
I didn't see it get released, but I saw it in the notes and when I clicked into it, I was like really kind of blown away by like, I mean, one, I think I'd like toyed around with something like an idea like this for the longest time.
I feel like everyone has.
Yeah.
And it's really, really cool to see it pop up.
Um, I was like, who created this?
And I did like some digging.
It was Charlie.
It was created by Charlie Erickson.
Yeah.
Um, he's pretty big in the bug bounty community.
I don't, I'm sure a lot of people kind of know who he is or have heard his name.
He is definitely very active in bug bounty forum.
Yeah.
That's where I know him.
And yeah, that's where I know him from as well.
Uh, it looks like he's kind of done a bunch of startup stuff in the past, uh, based on his like Twitter bio and stuff.
Um, I hadn't realized all these like companies and stuff that he'd done.
So it's a really cool product to see, uh, kind of pop up.
I would love to try it out.
I saw the price and I don't really want to pay that.
I got my hands on it, man.
I got my hands on it.
Oh, did you?
I did.
Yeah.
He, he, um, he actually sent me the beta for it.
Like months ago.
And I was like, wow, this is sick.
Like I got to talk about this on the podcast and we decided to hold off at the time because, you know, it was just kind of a beta mode and he was going to do a release around DEF CON, but now is the time to talk about it, man.
And I have to say like, the price is high for sure.
Like a thousand dollars per user per year.
That's pricey, man.
That's pricey.
And I feel like he kind of needs a, like a freemium of this, you know, like, I feel like he needs to, to release some.
Some part of it that's free.
And then, then, you know, or maybe even like a short trial to get you hooked on it because it's hard to take the bite to go straight into a thousand dollar a year product.
Um, yeah.
However, even the beta version that I played around with was pretty freaking sick.
Like it was, it was quite good.
And, um, he's added a lot of features since then.
The one that kind of blows me away the most go to, go to the website, right?
Yep.
And go to features, um, in the, in the tab, scroll down and then look at the, uh, fetch packed chunks.
Right.
He says, uh, yeah, so I think, I feel like everyone who's, who's ever like deep dived a JavaScript file, uh, or anyone who does that on a regular basis will know what this looks like.
Uh, essentially it's a function that will, you know, has a specific like name.
It's normally like number, colon, you know, name, you know, three, colon PDF, make seven, colon XLS.
And then there's another block.
And then there's a dot in that, and then it has a bunch of hashes.
And then at the end, it has dot JS.
So just from looking at it, you can clearly see they're, um, loading, they're constructing what a normal, uh, JS file looks like with like the hash and then the dash, and then the actual name of whatever it is, dot, dot JS or whatever.
Right.
Um, and so I, time and time again, have written scripts to decode this and get me access to these JavaScript files that are being, apparently he, they're, they're being lazy loaded.
That's what that the technical term is for that, like loaded, you know, sort of dynamically, uh, on the fly when needed.
And so if you never access, you know, the weird admin part of the application that actually loads it, then you'll never actually get the contents of that JS file, you know, in your browser.
But JS weasel somehow parses the JS code that does this, figures out how to, maybe there's like a common structure to it or something, figures out how to reverse this and auto download those JS files, which is really sick.
Um, yeah, it's super interesting.
I would be really, really curious to see how good it does, especially with same obfuscated and minified JavaScript.
I think that's generally the case where I find stuff has the biggest difficulty.
Just generally, like any sort of like parsing tool, whether it's symbol recognition or anything like that, obfuscated JavaScript generally throws a real big wrench into that.
I don't, it seems like it was kind of designed JavaScript that much though.
Like, I mean, obviously you could just get literally just a target.
I was looking at yesterday uses obfuscated job, like obfuscated and minified.
Oh my gosh, dude.
That's how I thought it was malware at first.
I thought it was malware.
That's good.
Yeah, no, I, I mean, I feel like maybe one in 50 targets that I look at use actual obfuscated JavaScript, which for any of you blue teamers out there, uh, that is a surefire way to piss off, uh, anyone who's trying to hack your app.
If there's like, if I, if all of your strings in the app are in hex, for Q like I, I hate that.
Like, so yeah, a hundred percent.
Yeah.
Um, I, I definitely, I'd like to get my hands on the latest version.
I'm kind of even, even, you know, with bug bounty being my full thing and, you know, pulling in a decent amount each year with, with money to allocate to tools and stuff like that.
I don't know, man.
I don't know if it's worth the one, one K, but I might, I might see if I can figure out it, but I also don't blame him for anchoring high, you know?
Like, yeah, I feel like maybe it would be better if he like framed it like, you know, $75 a month or something like that.
Cause I think what's a thousand divided by 12 is $83 a month.
Yeah.
Like if it was $83 a month, I might be more willing to click it instead of seeing a thousand dollars a year per user or something like that.
And I totally agree.
Like you got to make a profit somehow, like work isn't free.
Um, but I think if you look generally at like the bug bounty community and so many tools are free and or have like a trial or something like that, like there's very few tools that bug bounty hunters pay for.
Yeah, absolutely.
And so I think having a, uh, something that's useful like this, that you have to pay for and having it at such a high bar might be difficult to get bug bounty people to get on board with that.
You could probably sell it for like a quarter of this and get five times as many people signing up.
Oh yeah.
A lot.
So there's, there's probably some sort of like tweaking he's, he's going to have to do with that pricing and all that kind of stuff.
But in terms of like product and functionality and features, this looks really amazing.
Yeah, dude, I'm excited.
I hope the price does come down a little bit cause I would definitely use this.
Um, there's definitely, you know, product market fit here with, um, you know, the burp suite plugin.
Um, and you know, it's pushing right into this app.
That's how it works by the way, for any of you that, that aren't at the website, it, you have a burp suite plugin.
It shoves everything down to a VS code plugin that, um, just sucks it all up, beautifies it, adds a bunch of really cool, um, JS, uh, highlighting and, uh, like, you know, various layers of, of pulling stuff out of it.
And it'll, it'll deal with source maps, it'll deal with obfuscated JavaScript, it'll deal with chunks, like, um, so yeah, it's, it's really interesting.
It's funny because whenever I do JavaScript audits, I have like my own internal, like brain system that I use where like I figured out certain patterns that I notice within, uh, obfuscated or minified JavaScript or webpack JavaScript, whatever you want to call it.
And those, I'll like use those patterns to identify how stuff is working, but I never really go further than that.
I never ended up like writing scripts.
Okay.
I just like, I see my interest, what are these internal brain patterns?
Yeah.
So like, there's this, like one thing that I noticed a lot where webpack stuff, they'll often, when stuff gets packed together into one giant file, they'll name all the modules as numbers, like incremental numbers.
So that there'll be like, you know, module one, which was actually FS or something is now one.
And then there'll be some function called like N and it'll be like N with an argument one.
And then, you know, that it's, it's importing like module number one.
I know what you're talking about.
So you can search backwards.
And so you can say like, okay, where is the module with like one colon?
Like, where is that in the, in the module dictionary?
And then you can go and find the source and you can figure out what module is what.
Yeah.
And that's kind of like the system that I've always used, but this feels so much cleaner and more organized and more concrete than that.
And I think it would probably make for a lot less guesswork if it really works the way that it claims it does.
So yeah, yeah, this is a really, really awesome.
And I also like that the website looks just like a, like a GitHub product launch.
Oh, does it really?
It really does.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
With the big, with the big text, right.
And with one word, you know, highlighted.
It's true.
You're not wrong, man.
That's a good, that's a good call.
Um, all right, let's see what else we got.
Um, okay.
Uh, the only other thing that I really had on the list today was this, uh, like literally right before we started recording, freaking Rojan tweeted out, uh, a, uh, link to a talk that they had done at Tinder security labs, um, about an RCE in various services, uh, via, largely via GitHub actions, workflows.
Um, and exploding those, which is like pretty much the most Rojan thing I've ever heard in
my life.
Right.
Like he always goes after this, like out there, you know, bespoke stuff.
And, uh, uh, and so, yeah, I don't know.
Did you, did you see this at all?
Cause I actually didn't get the chance to actually, uh, check out the talk.
I just clicked through the slides before we launched the, yeah, I didn't, I didn't really get to check it out.
Um, it's kind of crazy.
I don't know if I should say, but maybe we'll cut this out, but I work with Rojan.
Right.
And, uh, you know, he's all, he's always doing really amazing research.
So it's cool to see some of this go public, um, and see it be talked about sort of on a more public stage.
Yeah, for sure.
All the internal communications that we have about it.
Um, but yeah, I mean, Rojan is obviously a very, very talented hacker.
Um, him and all the other people that, uh, that we have on our team are just some of the best, like bug bounty folks, as well as just hackers as a whole that, that, uh, that I know.
And so it's really awesome, uh, to have them on the team and see them do this kind of research.
And then you actually get to talk about it publicly at conferences.
Yeah, dude, not going to lie.
Um, I'm, I'm jealous of y'all's, y'all's team over there.
Rojan hit me up the other day about, wow, this is a while back actually about an opening on y'all's team.
And I was like, shoot, man, like if there's anything to pull me away from freaking full-time bug bounty, it would be a full-time research role on that team.
And I was like, ah, so.
Yeah.
I mean, I was just reading through one of their internal reports today and it's very like, I think you would, it would enjoy it if.
Oh my gosh.
You know, there was another opportunity that came up.
I think it would be something that would totally be your vibe because it's literally just like hacking.
It's just, yeah.
Heck man.
That, yeah, that sounds awesome.
So we'll link this, this report down in the, uh, in the description for the podcast or this, um, I guess these slides and, and YouTube video talk.
Um, yeah, should be some really high quality content.
Also, I just, I love injecting into the supply chain, right.
Rather than doing other stuff, you know, later after the product's been pushed, anything with like dependency confusion, attacking the continuous integration pipeline, all of that stuff.
Super cool.
And I happen to know a couple of other players in the space that are getting ready to launch products or will be launching products within the next year surrounding this that I think are going to really be very helpful.
Yeah, yeah, actually, now that I'm, I'm looking through all of, uh, all the slides on this.
Yeah, yes.
I did know a little bit about this.
Yeah.
But, uh, seeing, seeing the slides and seeing it like talked about definitely gives you a lot more context than, than what I had.
So I'm going to have to check out the actual video of the talk later.
Yeah, for sure.
I'll go, I'll go watch this as well.
Um, all right.
As, as we alluded to in the beginning of this episode with our debate, um, we are talking about sea surfs today.
Uh, and yeah, essentially I feel like sea surf is a vulnerability that a lot of people feel like got deleted with same site cookies and it's just not the case.
And there's some, you know, stringent conditions that you got to be on the lookout for, but I still see this all the time on all levels of hardenedness of target.
Um, so I was thinking we'd kind of dive into that today, discuss some techniques that we've seen, just have some technicalities and see where it takes us.
Yeah.
A hundred percent.
All righty.
Let's see.
Um, okay.
So first thing that I kind of wanted to talk about was for any of you that, that are out there that haven't heard of a sea surf, let's just go ahead and give a little, a little bit of a degree for that.
That is cross site request forgery.
Um, this attack occurs when the victim clicks on the link from the attacker, the attacker has control of the user's browser inside of the page.
And the attacker, um, somehow either by doing window.open or by doing a redirect or submitting an HTML form is able to push the user via redirection to some specific page on the victim application.
Um, you know, it could be a get request or it could be a post request.
And that, uh, that request will trigger some sort of functionality in that application and perform some action on behalf of the user.
Since that request is being done with the user's cookies.
Um, and yeah, go ahead.
Yeah.
Well, I was just gonna say, I think like the most like basic example that I can think of just going back to like my very, very early security days was bank account.
The, the, the typical example is that you are using bank.com and there's a transfer.
Endpoint that you can call to transfer money from your account to someone else's account.
And if there's a C-Surf there, then another website could force you to call that transfer endpoint using your own cookies in your own session and transfer money somewhere else.
And if there's no C-Surf check, then that could happen completely without anybody stopping that.
Yeah, for sure.
You know, that, that's what always made it click for me is just like, oh, it's you performing actions by yourself, but someone else is causing you to do it implicitly.
Yeah.
And, and dude, I, I, I've, I'm pretty sure that that example is in literally every piece of C-Surf education literature out there.
So I wonder if that ever happened.
Like, I wonder if the person that created, you know, or invented C-Surf was like.
Yeah, like 2002.
Whoa.
Yeah.
It's like.
I can make, what if I force the user?
Let me, let me log into my bank and see if this works, you know, like, and that's like the original writeup, you know, it's like passing around material on the dark web.
Like for bank.com you can trick, you know, trigger transfers.
I don't know why that's my voice for early day hackers.
Like maybe it's early 2000.
Yeah, exactly.
Like, I don't know, but, um, yeah, that would be interesting.
Uh, okay.
So everything was fine and dandy for years.
We were finding C-Surf's, uh, as they're affectionately named left and right.
Um, and then one fateful day, the same site cookie default lax setting was imposed by Chromium, the, you know, monster browser that destroys all of our hopes and dreams.
Um, and since then it has been a lot trickier to do that.
And the reason for that is, is that same site cookies, uh, are, uh, any cookie that's set now is being explicitly set to, or implicitly, excuse me, set to, um, lax, same site lax by default.
Um, what that means is that, um, there's only a very, there's a very specific set of conditions that must be completed, um, before you can trigger a request to be, with those cookies to be sent.
Um, those conditions are, uh, that you have to be making a top level navigation.
Um, so that means that the, essentially the URL bar up at the top has to be, um, changing in order for those cookies to be sent.
It can only be done with a get in a post request.
And with the post request, it can only be done within a two minute window of that cookie being set.
That is called the lax plus post, um, sort of caveat.
Uh, it's a temporary thing.
We don't know how long it's going to last.
I think it's probably going to last for a while.
Um, but that, that even may, may fade and fail us.
Um, so that's really interesting behavior that it's like, it feels almost very arbitrary that it's a two minute window.
Yeah.
And that it just kind of works because what happens like after, like, say that happens in the first five seconds.
Right.
Okay.
What about the other minute and 55 seconds?
Yeah.
I think, I think it, you know, it was just sort of a catch all for very slow loading single sign on services.
Um, so I'm not exactly sure, you know, why they, they chose two minutes arbitrarily.
Um, but I do think it's a cool, I think it's a cool, uh, technique and if you can still use it, it's very helpful for this technique.
I don't, you've probably seen this before, but exploiting that where you trigger a login or re-login.
Right.
And what that will do is get the cookie reset.
Um, and, and even if, you know, the user has already gotten established session, this can be done oftentimes with a get request in a window.open.
Right.
And then once the cookie is reset, that timer's got refreshed and then you can do a top level post, um, which will trigger the C-serve.
So it's very important nowadays, if you're going to try to find a post-based C-serve to have some sort of gadget, which will refresh the session, get that cookie reset so that you can, uh, take advantage of the LAX plus post window.
Yeah.
That's a, that's really interesting.
I mean, it's not like the biggest blocker, but it is kind of like an additional part of the chain that you now have to be aware of.
And, and I think if you were coming from a more traditional background and you just went to exploit a C-serve, you'd be like, why isn't this working?
And I think it's just cause it's like, there's new, there's new levels that are now at play here.
Yeah, for sure.
And so go, go, do you see this link that I put in there, um, with, by Teddy cats?
You see that?
Uh, yes.
Yeah.
Click on that really quick.
We can talk through this volume.
I think this one's really cool.
Um, so I want to add, so before we jump into that, uh, I'm, I'm going to go ahead and talk about the conditions for the modern conditions, the, the, the now conditions for a C-serve.
Right.
Um, and those are this, the content type must be text plain, XWW form URL encoded, or multi-part form data.
One of those three, right?
There might be other ones.
I, I feel like I've seen text slash JSON being used before in a C-serve.
I could be wrong about that.
And we're not talking about any of this flash stuff that you can do with flash.
That's, that's outdated.
No one uses that anymore.
Um, so it must be one of those three.
The request must be a get or a post request, and it must be a top level navigation.
So the, the URL bar at the top needs to change as a result.
Um, and that will result in the, the cookies being sent, uh, under the same site, under the, the rule of this cruel, cruel, you know, monarch, the, the same site cookie.
Um, the exception to that is this, is this cool blog post that I linked here.
So let's take a look at that.
Yeah.
The, uh, this is by Teddy cats.
Yeah, dude.
This guy is Brock on his blog about GitHub.
Oh, off, um, bypass.
Yeah.
So this guy is pretty much exclusively a, a GitHub hacker as far as I can see.
And I just freaking loved this bug.
So, um, did you get a chance to see it before the, the pod or am I, am I preaching to you as well?
Dude, I think I've actually, I feel like I read this a long time ago because I've hacked GitHub since this blog post came out in the years since this has come out.
And so I feel like I have seen something along the lines of this, but I don't know if I've read it specifically.
So go ahead.
You're not totally.
Dude, I feel, I feel kind of bad because like, I, I do this thing where I go to people's blogs before a live hacking event that are like really good at hacking the target that we're going to hack.
And I just read all of them, right?
Like very fresh, right?
Very fresh in my memory.
And twice in 2022, I found volumes and, and the people that wrote about those, that using the techniques from those blogs and the people that wrote those blogs duped to me.
So I got the main report and they got the duper.
And they're like, bro, I should never have blogged about this, which is very, which is very sad.
You know, cause it's like, we do like to see sharing in the community and stuff, but also like, you know, can't hate, what is it?
What do they say?
Don't hate the player, hate the game, hate the, hate the game.
Don't hate the player.
Something like that.
Yeah.
Um, all right.
So yeah, this, this, this specific one, pretty cool.
Uh, we'll link it.
It's called bypassing GitHub's, uh, OAuth flow.
This is an example of C-Surf that does not use get or post.
This is a, uh, C-Surf done with a head request, um, which was, which was really interesting to me.
Um, essentially the TLDR of this is that the, get, uh, the head request gets routed to the same spot in the application.
Um, I want to say this is, is this rails?
Yeah, it's rails.
So the, the way that the rails router is defined, it says, you know, match the specific path and then there's, um, via, and then you provide a list of, uh, uh, you know, valid, um, uh, HTTP verbs.
Yeah.
Thank you.
I couldn't come up with it.
Yeah.
You provide get in post.
Um, and then, so there's just get in post in this array in the blog post, but, um, there's also some quirk in rails where they just want head to kind of work seamlessly.
They don't want you to have to be able to have to like, you know, work on head being something different than get.
Right.
So head also gets routed to wherever get is, is, uh, routed to.
And inside.
Super interesting.
Yeah.
I thought so too.
And, and inside the request, um, it's, you know, inside the function that deals with this route, it, it, there is this, uh, if statement that says, if the request, if request.get, then do this.
Right.
Otherwise do that.
So it's not checking, you know, it's a pretty safe, to be honest.
Like I would have definitely not caught this in code review because it's like, okay, get only getting poster allowed, but, uh, and we've got get.
So the only alternative can be post.
Right.
But that's not quite the case.
So the head method can also, um, trigger this.
And it actually, in this case, it was triggering the same thing as a post request would do, which allowed for the, um, the OAuth bypass, uh, which landed him a pretty sick.
But I think there was a 25 K bounty, right?
25 K.
Yeah.
It was.
That's really interesting.
Um, honestly, I would have expected that a head request would behave more like a get request than a post request.
So I would have expected it exactly if it was going to be an implicit thing like this, it would go through the, the get handler, but, uh, you know, maybe it was actually, you know, coming through as like request dot head or something.
So if you look at the check where it says if it's request dot get, and then else is catching everything else.
And so it doesn't even have to be behaving like a post request.
It's just, if it's not a get request, then it does this alternative behavior, which would be to grant permissions.
I wonder if options does the same thing.
I assume it probably does because head and options are special cases, right?
Where those are really meant for the browser to do pre, pre-check requests and that kind of stuff to make sure that the endpoints exist or are reachable and that kind of stuff.
Right?
Yeah, I, I thought the same thing before I, you know, while prepping for this episode and I looked into it and I think options, at least normally they're sent by the browser without any, um, authentication attached to them.
I, I'll have to double check on that, uh, cause this is a while back, but, um, if they are sent with, uh, authentication attached to them, that could be a really interesting way to potentially exploit some of this behavior.
Yeah.
I would imagine that the browser won't be sending it now, but maybe they have to, you know,
because maybe like an option or options request would fail if it doesn't have the right authentication on it.
I don't really know.
Yeah.
Um, but that might be an interesting area to, to target.
For sure.
Yeah.
So this is also just a good, I feel like this is just a good quirk to, to know about in rails as well is, is that head will get routed to the same point place that get will.
And if there is this sort of, you know, if get else do this sort of mentality, then this bug could vary.
Well, I, I, I absolutely anticipate that this bug has, is present in other code bases as well.
Yeah.
I mean, it's gotta be, I can't imagine that.
Um, I mean, Ruby is very, very commonly used and this seems like a strange type of implicit behavior for it to be there.
Yeah.
So I wouldn't be surprised if it has other implications, as you can tell in the blog post, this is actually down to how GitHub is implementing it.
Right.
Where it's not really like an implicit vulnerability.
It's just that the fact that how they're handling whether or not it's a get request or some other type of request is influencing the behavior of the app.
And so if there's other services that are written in rails that aren't doing an explicit check for a head or an options, or they're doing some sort of fallback behavior like this is, then you'd be able to exploit that in the same way.
Yeah.
I totally agree.
So just as a, as a, as a takeaway, you know, uh, list a couple of takeaways here, rails, uh, definitely play around with head requests for that.
Um, for C-Surf, you need to have content type text plane, X form, uh, XWB form URL encoded or multi-part.
It needs to be get a post or a head likely, uh, request, and it must be a top level navigation.
That's kind of interesting to me though, because this was before, now that I'm saying all of this together, this was before same site cookies.
This was 2019.
So I'm wondering if head requests, I'm wondering if that even works anymore, because I don't know that you can send a head request.
Via top level navigation.
So how would you get the cookie to send?
Yeah.
I wonder.
It might, it might have to be coupled with a, yeah, it might have to be coupled with a, uh, with a, like insecure configuration for same site or something like that in order to actually get this to work.
Yeah.
Cause when did same site come out?
That was like 2020.
Yeah.
February 4th, 2020 stat in the heart, man.
Super interesting.
Um, yeah.
So those are the takeaways there.
Um, let's talk a little bit about some exploitation techniques and then we'll kind of jump.
Um, I mean, do you have anything you want to talk about for mobile C-Surf?
Uh, I'm not, I'm not sure if you're where, I guess, CARF as we affectionately named it.
Yeah.
So a lot of that stuff we've talked about during the mobile app, um, episode, but I think generally it's the same kind of stuff that you'd already be looking for.
So JavaScript bridges expose URL schemas.
Um, if there is any kind of internal web view, the non-exposed URL schemas are also a good target for that because if you can find some way to point the internal web view to an arbitrary URL, then you can potentially exploit those internal URL schemas that would be only accessible from within the app.
Um, and you may be able to escalate that further to do who knows what, but, uh, that, that I'll actually talk a little bit about that when we talk about our specific bugs.
Cause the specific bug I have is very similar to that.
Sweet.
So we'll, we'll wait for that then.
Um, let me, so I, I wrote down a bunch of exploitation techniques here.
Let's just kind of roll through them one by one.
Um, oh, well actually, okay.
Okay.
Actually, before we get into this section, I do want to add one more thing about same site.
Um, if you, if you have any, um, questions or concerns about same site, uh, definitely check out the Jew Bob's post, the great same site confusion.
We've talked about it on the pod several times before.
Really good stuff.
Um, the, so on the note of same site though, there is this thing, same site strict, which is rare, but I actually have seen it and I've got a funny story about it, dude, actually.
So did you meet, did you meet, uh, so Sakaguchi, did you meet one of my, one of my friends that was from Japan that I feel like you might've met him in Vegas or in, uh, Austin.
Yeah.
I wasn't at either of the last Vegas or Austin events.
So you were in Vegas, weren't you?
No, I had, I was supposed to come, but then I had to cancel last minute.
Cause I had a thing happen last year.
You might not, you might not have met him then, but you, was he one of the people that flew over and, and stayed with you?
Yeah.
So he was, so we were hacking together.
I was just a little bit.
Yeah.
I, he's one of my friends from Japan.
Um, great hacker.
Now I was training him, you know, with some stuff and there's this, there's this app that I guess I can't specify.
Um, and it, it looks very vulnerable to see surf.
Right.
But here's the thing.
It deletes your account and he actually uses the app.
Right.
So I'm like, so we caught the request, right?
We caught the request in, in burp and we're like, okay, you know, like, look, there's no, you know, see surf tokens.
There's no, there's no origin checks here.
It doesn't look like there's an origin check.
I guess you can't know until you submit it.
Um, uh, but you know, it looks good.
And we had found other bugs that look similar to this in the past on that, on that website.
So I was like, okay, man, like, here's the deal.
We gotta, we gotta, we gotta just build the POC and give it a shot.
Like this is a several thousand dollar bug here.
Like, and, and, oh, and, and the, the process for creating an account was really long and hard and had, had required phone numbers and all sorts of, right?
Okay.
Yeah.
So we can't really just create another.
So, so we, we, we run the exploit on his account fully expected to be getting, you know, hearing cha-ching noises and, um, and I don't know how it ended up, you know, being this way, but, uh, they had same site strict, right?
So we, we, we deleted his account with something else, uh, you know, to try to prove it, you know, that the origin check wasn't working.
It's like, okay, great.
You know, this is good.
And we go back to do it again with another account and the same site strict cookies.
They have same site strict on, which means that there's, that you will never, it will never send a cookie to a, from one site to another site.
There's no, not a get request, not a poet request.
It just doesn't happen.
Right.
And so at the end, it wasn't vulnerable to, to C-Surf and we deleted his whole account on this app.
He just deleted his whole account?
Yeah.
Oh no.
It was so bad.
It was on a music app that was, that, that was popular, um, that, where he lives.
So I felt really bad, man.
Uh, yeah, it's funny.
Cause I was actually looking back at, um, I did have like a really low impact CSRF that I reported like many, many years ago.
And it was like, I don't even think I tested it like in the traditional way because same site wasn't a thing.
Right.
So all I did was check if I set origin to null, then does it work?
Yes.
And like it redirected me to an arbitrary domain.
Well, if there's no, if there's no, um, you know, if there's no other checks, if there's no refer check, if there's, which can be circumvented, if there's no, you know, C-Surf tokens in the request, you'd think it would be, you know?
Right.
But, right.
All right.
Yeah.
Vulnerable, but not exploitable.
Exploitation techniques.
So, um, just a couple of things I just want to note on this.
You know, these are just kind of pro tip section on C-Surf.
Look at the same site values for your cookies.
Okay.
So one thing that I will, I will notice, Joel, did you just literally just OCD out?
Listen, I'm sorry.
What is wrong with you?
So literally in the doc, I wrote same site.
Yeah, I wasn't expecting you to get called out about this.
No, you're getting called out for that, dude.
I literally wrote same site with no capitalization and no dash in the middle in the notes.
And while we're talking about this.
There's just one lowercase word, same site.
Joel goes in here and capitalizes it and adds the dash like a total maniac.
Um, I was like, look, now I know that it's, it's same site.
Now it's same site, not, not same site, you know, some site.
Um, but yeah, so the tip that I was going to say with this is make sure you're checking
your cookies.
Um, note that same site, if, if same site is not set, if the same site attribute is not
set on a cookie, then that will be same site lacks by default, which is different than
same site lacks explicit.
Okay.
Same site lacks explicit when it's explicitly set, um, does, is not subject to the lax plus
post, um, sort of, uh, accommodation that they've made for people transitioning.
Because if you're setting it explicitly, then you obviously you're not one of the people
that's transitioning to a architecture that supports this.
So that can be a gotcha, uh, that can get you some NAs or some informatives if you don't
check that.
Um, so yeah, keep an eye on that.
Um, let's, um, yeah.
Another thing was the method params.
Um, I've seen this a lot on Ruby, especially, uh, there's like a really weird.
Man, Ruby's getting wrecked today.
Yeah.
Ruby, Ruby's super weird.
I think this is specifically some like weird rails configuration or something, but there's
like a method parameter that you can put in the URL and it will allow you to change the
method of your request.
Even if it's sent as a get request, you can have it send it as a, like a post request
and say it gets interpreted on the backend as like a post request.
And that adds all sorts of different levels of complexity now, because you can send a get
requests with the body.
Right?
Yeah.
I, I'm not sure if you can make the browser do that though.
Can you?
Yeah.
I don't, that's the one caveat is again, it's like vulnerable, but not exploitable where
yeah.
Yeah.
I don't, I'm not, I'm not sure that would be a kind of interesting area to research.
Cause it would be, it would be, but I feel like most of the, um, you know, routing software,
most of the, the web servers would, um, just kind of consider those body either just delete
those body params on a, on a get request, uh, or just stick them as they were, you know,
a query parameter.
So I'm not, I'm not sure how that would get, get parsed, but like you said, you know, there's
definitely the option of sending a get request and then setting this method equals post, right?
And then having the server parse it as a post request.
That's a really good method.
Yep.
Let me grab some water.
Heck, I'm out of water.
Um, yeah, I'm just going to cough into the mic real quick here.
Um, yeah, this is how we know when we need to wrap up the episodes is like Justin's out
of water, his third is dying.
Um, yeah, so let, let me look at some of these other, uh, yeah.
So obviously, you know, get, you, you want to be looking for any get based requests that
will, um, result in some change in the application, right?
Cause if you have that, you're pretty much just set anyway, unless they're setting some
weird, you know, header or something like that.
Um, so be on the lookout for that.
Um, and then the other, the other thing, which we alluded to earlier is I feel like, and this
is sort of, I'm going to release something else on the pod about this later, but I feel
like not enough people when they look at applications are keeping in mind various gadgets that they
need, right?
These are parts of chains.
These are links in your chain that, that you need to find.
So for example, if you hack all day and you don't find anything, you can feel like garbage,
right?
Or you can look back and you can say, okay, well now I know that if I go to this specific
area of the application, I'll get this error error that will tell me, you know, this about
the application.
Or if I provide a valid ID here and an invalid ID, then it allows me to validate which IDs
are, are, you know, valid or not valid.
Or I found this end point that I can force the user to refresh their session cookie, right?
That's the most applicable in this scenario.
Those gadgets are very valuable.
So even if you haven't found a bug, make sure you're noting down these gadgets.
And those, if you are, and you're keeping those in the front of your mind, your, your
brain will figure out a way to utilize these and figure out a way to chain these into, you
know, different bugs.
If you're skipping over them, if you're not emphasizing these, then, you know, you're never
just going to get the full chain into place.
So that's another, that's another tip.
That sort of gadget based methodology.
Yeah, for sure.
And we've talked about like notes, you need to take notes.
Yeah.
Just like if you find something that's weird or, or strange behavior, probably not like
quite a bug, but could be used with something else to become a bug.
I don't like ID leaks, anything like that.
If they're using a UUID and you find something at least leaks a list of UUIDs, that's a great
thing that you can chain together as like a gadget where by itself, maybe it's not the most
severe thing, but if you can then find an ID where that uses that ID, that makes it so
much more severe.
So anything that's like along those lines, just be keeping notes of the different like
weird behaviors that you're seeing.
And this is about, as we say, becoming intimate with the application.
It is, man.
It is.
This is part of the process of understanding how does the application work?
What are the different moving parts?
What are the different functionalities that exist?
Is one specific part not secure that can then be used with another specific part that's
not secure to then leverage that further?
Those are the types of things that we really want to look for.
Yeah.
Yeah, for sure.
I think, yeah.
And so there's lots of different ways that you can approach these vulnerabilities, these
applications that you're trying to find.
And we're not trying to say, you know, everyone needs to take notes.
Everyone needs to keep in mind the gadgets.
But that's something that's definitely worked for me quite a bit in the past.
And I think it's a helpful methodology.
Let's see.
Let's see what else we got here.
Okay.
Well, this is an interesting one.
So if you, and we tweeted about this a little bit as well when Rezo mentioned something like
this, but one of the main ways that I find CSERF nowadays is servers that are using just plain
JSON requests.
And, you know, as we know, JSON as a content type is not vulnerable to cross-site request
forgery.
However, excuse me, however, if you, if you change the content type from JSON to text plain
or for to XWW form URL encoded, then it may be vulnerable.
It could be that the server is parsing that content type, or if you're sending text plain,
it could just consider that as JSON.
So those are good areas to check.
It normally only takes one or two different checks because I guess maybe this is my experience.
I won't prime you otherwise, but in my experience, you know, I don't check every single endpoint
for this.
I check like one or two endpoints for this to see if like, you know, the server actually
just at all just does not mess with, you know, XWW formula encoded or text plain.
I don't test all of them, but I could be missing some there.
So I, you know, whatever testing style fits you best, as long as you're checking if you
can convert content types.
Yeah, for sure.
I, you know, I think it's, if you think about it from a developer's perspective, it's probably
going to be implemented in like one place.
So it's going to be added as a middleware or a content type handler for the entire server
versus being on an endpoint by endpoint basis, because usually it's being processed at a lower
level than it is like at the route handler.
It's probably going to be on the server level.
So I think your testing methodology there probably makes sense to just like see if this
host is vulnerable to that type of confusion or changing of types and see if it's flexible
in that way of parsing.
And then if it's not, I wouldn't waste too much time.
So I think it's really interesting to think about how CSRF is one of the more like old
school type of vulnerabilities because the way that it gets exploited is still using a form
element.
You know what I mean?
It's not like anything crazy.
It's not like custom modern JS.
It's literally just a form, you know, it's just a form HTML element.
And so you do get restricted by some of those bounds in terms of how a form element actually
works, what capabilities it has, what content type it is, how it encodes data, all that kind
of stuff, which is why it needs to be either text plain or form URL encoded because forms don't
send JSON and apps that are sending JSON are typically JavaScript based where you're clicking a
button and that's triggering an on click handler, which is then making a fetch request or whatever
it is in the backend that's actually triggering the API request versus sending a very, you know,
traditional HTML form.
Yeah.
And I liked what you said about HTML sort of being limited by old HTML in that capacity because
we do still exploit CSRFs via form elements.
And I'm looking right now.
You can set the content type on a form element using the ENC type attribute and the method via the
method attribute.
I'm a little salty because I went and looked into this ENC type attribute the other day and it would
be really cool if we could specify not only the content type, but the character encoding in here as
well, you know, because you could do, because we were looking into, this is a little bit of a rabbit trail,
but we were looking into bypassing WAFs, you know, payloads using encoding.
I think Saroosh tweeted something out about that.
And we were just kind of going back and forth on it.
I was like, man, I wonder if we can force the browser to send a request using
UTF-7 or something like that, right?
And I was thinking, man, that the ENC type should, ENC type should do it.
And I think even the HTML spec mentions that it should be able to do it, but it freaking doesn't
do it, man.
That is salty.
Well, I mean, this wouldn't be the first time where the HTML spec says one thing and every single
thing on the internet says that the spec follows this one thing and it doesn't.
So maybe it's worth looking into and actually verifying.
Honestly, since that thing that we found with the base element, it really has me wondering how
much of HTML is strictly enforced to what the spec says it should be and how much flexibility
there is in terms of weird edge cases and stuff like this.
Yeah, I'm sure there's tons, just more and more to uncover.
So the other, a couple other little things I had here, obviously making sure you're changing
your post request to get request.
It's one of the, I pretty much forced Kaido to do that because I told them like, hey, I
like this is one of the main features I use in Burp, you know, this change request
functionality.
So they did put it into Kaido, which is great.
Um, and so converting your post request to your get request makes it really easy to, to check.
Um, and then, uh, so the other thing that I kind of wanted to mention was sometimes they'll,
companies will do sneaky stuff like check the origin header and check the refer header to
ensure to further C-SERF checks.
And those-
Which is technically proper C-SERF protection.
That plus a C-SERF token is really, I believe the recommendation, or at least it was.
It can be.
There is, there is ways, there are, there is ways, there are ways to bypass that.
Um, so for the origin, uh, and, and I guess if it's configured properly, there's not ways
to bypass it.
But for the origin, you can get the origin to be set to null for a request by doing it
within a iframe that is the source of that iframe, the source attribute of that iframe is
a data URI.
Um, and that will remove the origin from that, from that, um, uh, iframe and, uh, allow you
to just, you know, run your HTML, um, document that you've defined inside of that, that data
URI inside of there.
And then you can try to trigger it that way.
Um, I'm wondering now that I'm saying it, cause a lot of these techniques are, are a little
antiquated, I'm wondering that, that isn't going to, that isn't going to pass the same
site checks now though.
Right.
I don't, I don't know.
I, I, I'm, I'm going to research that.
With cores and CSP, you'd also get blocked a lot of the time by not having the right URL
or not being able to even open data URLs.
Yeah.
CSP.
I need, I need to look that up and see if there's any way, is there, yeah, I'm going to research
this any afterwards, any way to send a request, um, with the null in the origin, um, with nowadays
same site stuff that that's kind of interesting.
I, I sort of didn't apply the same site stuff in my brain to this technique.
So, so that's that, um, perhaps maybe an origin check might be enough nowadays.
Uh, uh, you know, especially if you are handling the null case, it would definitely be enough
like, like you were saying.
Yeah.
Um, but if you're not handling the null case, it could still be enough because the browser
may not allow you to do it.
Um, the only other one was the referrer.
And I was going to say this one, um, this is not as, excuse me, this is not a secure technique
for C-Surf, uh, because we have the ability to control the refer policy, which determines,
um, what is set.
Right.
And actually, oh, I, I didn't even write this down, Joel, but I actually had a cool bug that
I, that I found the other day because of this, because what it was doing, um, was it was sending
this, ah, gosh, I love this bug.
I can't believe I didn't get this in the notes for this episode.
Um, so here's what it was.
I'm just going to drop everything and tell you about it right now.
Um, uh, so it was a C-Surf.
It was a C-Surf.
Of course.
Um, and it was doing, uh, the C-Surf check via the referrer.
Right.
And so I was like, okay, you know, easy peasy.
And all it was doing, it was checking to make sure that, um, site, uh, you know, site.com
slash was in the referrer.
So I was like, okay, uh, easy peasy.
I should just be able to, um, create a folder called site, you know, site.com slash and execute
my explain from there.
And then that should pass the check.
Right.
Um, wrong because, uh, you can't do that.
You can't, whenever you're sending, they, they deleted the referrer parameter, uh, the
paths from the referrer parameter nowadays.
Right.
Um, okay.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Oh, interesting.
It just sends by default.
It just sends, you know, HTTPS, uh, you know, the top level, the FQDN slash to crossword.
I thought that was only for org.
I thought that was only for origins.
What do you mean?
I thought only origin headers did that behavior.
I didn't know that refers because that was a big problem for a long time where API tokens
and stuff would get, excuse me, we'd get leaked through a referrer header because referrer
is the exact referrer URL, whereas origin would be just the origin URL.
Exactly.
That, and, and I think that's the reason why they removed it was because, because it was
lit because what you could do is you could get an HTML injection, right?
With an image tag and then redirect the user to that specific page, um, you know, with their
access token and URL.
And that access token would get leaked by the referrer to, you know, your image that you
inject into the page and you're boom, you got an ATO.
Um, right.
But anyway, they removed that.
And so I bypassed it because you can actually set the referrer policy on your own page to
send the full URL.
Um, you, you, it doesn't have to be, uh, you know, since you control the, the page that
you're sending from, you can use it.
I think it's a meta tag.
Um, you should look that up really quick.
You see, see if you can find anything, but, um, the, the meta tag, I believe allows you
to set the referrer policy and what, and there are several options for that.
One of those is send the full URL in the referrer.
Um, and so plop that into my page, um, you know, sent the user to that page and it sent
the full URL, which allowed me to bypass the C-Surf check and got, got the bug.
Um, so I, I don't know, man, that, that sort of fringe stuff like that just gets my blood
pumping.
I love it.
Yeah.
So there's actually two ways to do it there.
You can set it, um, as a header refer dash policy, like no refer origin, same origin, strict
origin, unsafe URL.
And then you can also set it with HTML through a meta tag.
Like you thought meta, the name is refer and then the content would be like origin, for
example.
Interesting.
Yeah.
I think I'm looking at the same page that you are.
The Mozilla docs.
Yeah.
The, the meta, the meta tag is so interesting, dude.
Like, cause, cause I.
A lot of functionality.
Yeah.
We were kind of deep diving this last time with like, you know, when we were looking
into base and stuff like that, but, um, this doesn't even use the HTTP equiv attribute, um,
uh, you know, to, to like pretend like it's an HTTP header, right?
This is actually just a different thing.
So I gotta, I gotta go, I gotta find some way to just read everything that a meta tag can
do.
Cause I'm sure there's some weird stuff there.
Yeah.
And I, I'm not really sure where the best, like the right place to look either, because
I feel like if, even if we look at the HTML spec, it's not really what you need to look
at.
It's, you should probably look at like the Chrome source code or something like that.
Dude.
I don't want to look at the Chrome source code, man.
That hurts my eyes.
Don't like that.
Yeah.
Me neither.
Um, cool.
All right.
So that's, that's, uh, yeah, that's all I had for the actual, um, content of the sea
surf stuff.
Yep.
Yeah.
That's all I had.
You want to go into bugs real quick?
Yeah.
Let's do it, man.
Okay.
So I already, I already presented one bug cause I just got hype.
I just, I love that man.
But yeah, this next one is actually really cool too.
So this is a, a sea surf that I found, um, at a live hacking event in, um, 2022.
Um, and there was this obscure domain that was way out there, right?
That, that no, you super old legacy garbage.
And there's some like weird trickery.
I figured out a way to get an account on that domain.
Um, there's like a hidden signup page that was like, I found him like a way back archive
thing.
Right.
So I got there, got into that app and I'm like seeing dollar signs at this point.
Cause it's like, it was in scope too.
They had star in scope.
So I was like, oh, this is clutch.
And, and I did get like, you know, five figures worth of bounties, um, from that specific,
uh, domain.
One of them was the sea surf, which was, which was cool.
Um, now how this one worked was it, it sort of had four parts of the chain.
Okay.
Um, so I needed to send two top level requests that this, this required one click.
So you come to the attacker's page and it triggers one click.
Um, from that I could trigger two pieces of code.
Okay.
I could trigger, um, there's a little hack here.
You can use the, the form, uh, the button within the form.
Um, you can harvest one click and get two actions to be triggered.
You can get a form submission because the button got clicked and you can also use the on click.
Um, so this actually allowed me to open up two pages with one click.
Um, and so the first thing that I did was I say, I see served, log in, see served the victim
into this old legacy website from the main website.
I found a way to do that where you can, you know, transfer the user in.
Okay.
Then the second request, which was still pending by the way, um, that was sent to a, uh, PHP
script on my server that, uh, was set to sleep for like two seconds or whatever.
Right.
So it sort of delays and make sure that the user is actually authed into the website first.
Then it, it redirects the victim.
I think I had to do a 307 too, cause I think it was a post request.
Um, I'd issue a 307, which redirects the user to it to with the same method, uh, post method
to a different URL, um, where the sea surf actually occurred.
Um, and all of this was happening, um, you know, when the user came to the attacker's page
and, and it was actually a sea surf to affect the user's account in that sort of weird, obscure,
you know, domain, which is not very impactful.
And I thought that they wouldn't like it, but, um, the, the, you know, through the data
pipelines, that data actually ends up back on the main application and had some, some pretty
painful effects on the main application.
Um, so that ended up getting accepted.
It used a couple of cool tricks, which is why I, I mentioned it used this double sort of
on click thing.
And then also the delay script, I think was a nice piece as well.
Yeah.
That's super interesting that, that, uh, that aspect of sort of the double, the double
action where you click a button and you, you take advantage of the on click as well as the
native form element behavior.
Yeah.
It's an interesting little trick.
I have to refresh that in my mind because there are definitely scenarios where you need
to, to click triggered actions.
Um, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Super interesting.
All right.
What you got for yours?
Okay.
So for my, mine is more like, uh, the kind of thing that I talked about where it's, it's
basically the closest you can get to a sea surf without it being a carve.
Um, okay.
Wait, without it being a carve?
It's not cross app.
Yeah.
So it's not cross app, but it is cross domain within the app.
Nice.
Essentially.
Um, I think I can talk about this.
Uh, uh, yes, they're public.
Okay.
So TikTok, everybody knows TikTok.
Um, uh, this was way back before TikTok was popular.
This was in 2019.
Um, and so TikTok, I don't know if they still have this functionality, but essentially you
could scan a QR code within the app and that would, I think, take you to somebody's profile
or take them, take you to like a post or something like that.
It was built in.
Um, but the thing is that QR codes can have a lot of different data encoded to them.
Right.
And so I realized that you could just encode an arbitrary QR code pointing to a URL and it
would open it within the app, in the internal web view within the app, because the way that
it routed was that it would try and use the internal URL schemas.
And typically it would be encoded with some, you know, internal schema that would open someone's
profile or something like that.
But you, if you put just HTTP in there, then it'll open it in an internal web view.
So wait, so this is, do you have to scan it within the TikTok app or can you just scan
it with your phone?
You have to scan it within the app, right?
Within the app.
Yeah.
So the attack scenario would be like, you know, you open your TikTok app, you go and
scan some QR code to go to someone's profile, you get popped.
Right.
Um, and so basically this would open up an internal web view that then had access to this
JavaScript bridge and a bunch of other internal functionality that you could then take advantage
of because typically they weren't expecting that you would be within this context.
And so there was a whole bunch of different checks in terms of like the functions and stuff
that you could call.
But there was this caveat, which is that the, the, if you were like calling the JavaScript
bridge, it had this check called is safe host.
And it would essentially, it had a list of allowed URLs.
Uh, the problem is that it was checking if host.equals or host.endswith blank, then proceed.
And you may have picked up on this already, but .endswith is not safe.
Um, if it was just .equals, that would have been fine.
But .endswith is very, very flexible.
.endswith and then with no preceding . is that correct?
Correct.
And so a lot of domains in the list did have subdomains.
However, for example, tiktok.com did not.
And so I purchased the domain not tiktok.com.
Nice.
Explain tiktok.com.
And I registered it.
Yes.
And it was like $5.
Yeah.
And so I put together a POC.
And basically if you scan a URL, it points to not tiktok.com with my POC.
It would open it up.
And then from there, because it passes the host check, you're able to talk with the JavaScript
bridge.
And so there was a ton of functionality behind this.
Once you get past that check where you could create pop-ups within the app, you could install
APKs.
Dude.
You could prompt the user.
You could pull down user information about who the current user is.
So there was like a ton of functionality that you could do from that point.
And that's kind of like the C-Serve aspect where it's on my post.
It's on not tiktok.com.
But I'm talking with the app over the JavaScript bridge, over the internal URL schemas, and I'm
getting information across app that I really shouldn't be able to.
So it's kind of like cores, kind of like CSRF, you know.
But yeah, that's kind of my mobile example.
And I think there's a ton of other examples out there that are more the CARF stuff that
we talked about where it's like creating intents from a third-party app that then do something
similar where it's exploiting app functionality that you normally wouldn't be able to reach
unless you were coming from a third-party app or from some third-party standpoint, like
a web view within the app or something like that.
For sure.
That's a cool technique because there are a lot of apps that have built-in QR code scanners.
So I bet other apps that have bug bounty programs out there are vulnerable to opening the web view
via a QR code like that, right?
With just a domain.
And you might have to sort of double-click into the code a little bit to see if there
are like an origin check or something like that.
But dude, I love those moments when you get in there and you're like, gosh, shoot, there's
an origin check.
Like, ah, I'm in trouble.
And then you look at it, it's like ends with, and you're like, yes, I love that.
Yeah, exactly.
Exactly.
Oh, man, it just freaking gets the blood pumping.
Yeah, so don't, you know, if you see something, look into it fully until you're for sure that
it can't be exploited because lots of times there'll be weird checks like that.
Good stuff, man.
All right.
Anything else we want to cover before we wrap up today?
Oh, yes.
One thing.
So you may have seen on Twitter, Nahamsec, Ben, our buddy.
He is on his way.
He's very, very close to 100,000 subscribers on YouTube.
Yeah.
Um, so I think he's, let me double check where his actual number is, but yeah, I think
he was at like 95K, 94K, 95K.
So he has a goal.
He'd love to hit 100K before DEF CON.
And if he does, he's going to shave his whole beard.
He's going to shave his whole head.
Dude, he's going to be hairless.
Dude, I wonder if we can get him to do the eyebrows too.
Yeah, maybe eyebrows too.
So definitely, if you aren't already, go check out Nahamsec's channel.
It's at Nahamsec on YouTube and give him a subscription.
He's pumping out amazing content.
He live streams.
He does so much insightful stuff, kind of similar to the stuff that we do, but like on another
level.
And yeah, definitely, definitely would recommend going and looking at his channel and looking
at his content.
That's the call to action for today, y'all.
You know, today.
Subscribe to Ben.
Go to Nahamsec's channel.
Hit that subscribe button.
We want to see a bald and eyebrow-less Nahamsec, so please do that for us.
It's actually a win-win for Ben, right?
Because he gets, you know, he's got like 100K subscribers, right?
So he's like, you know, pretty well known.
And I'm sure if he goes to DEF CON, people are going to be like, ah, Nahamsec, you know,
awesome.
But, you know, let's get a picture together or something like that, right?
So if he does get up to 100K subscribers, then he gets 100K subscribers.
And he also gets to shave his head and his beard and his eyebrows and no one's going to notice
him.
So he can just kind of, you know, skate around, you know, DEF CON like he's not famous.
Yeah.
Then all the photos will be great memories of.
Oh, that's true.
But the people that do recognize him
will have a priceless photo forever.
Exactly, exactly.
It's like a limited edition, the Homsack.
Limited edition, the Homsack.
Dude, Rick, it's not a good year for me to skip DEF CON, heck.
Yeah, yeah, you're really missing out.
But I understand, there are more important life events.
There are, man.
There are.
Yes, for sure.
All right, with that, that's a wrap, yeah?
Yep, that's a wrap.
Peace.
I'll see you next time.